[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm link and I'm
rat it's time for another conversation
with someone interesting from the
internet and this week the person who
joins us at the roundtable of dim
lighting is Joe Bereta now you probably
know Joe in one of two ways or maybe two
of two ways they both you might know I'm
for both a lot of people probably do
he's one half of the comedy duo barats
and bereta and he's also the head writer
in the hosts of YouTube channel
SourceFed now he and luke barats formed
the dynamic duo of beretta beretta way
back at the dawn of internet
civilization which was December 2005 and
their first big viral video which he
talks about is Mother's Day comment
coming closer you're not in the frame
you're not afraid I swear to god you're
like halfway out of the picture right
now
yeah Tucker why do you want me so close
to you anyways I want I want you in the
picture someone can see you Oh pigs
happy Mother's Day mom Tucker wants me
hoping his shoulder I certainly remember
watching that video at the time Tim
dated this is this is amazing they
continue to grow a cult following of
sketch videos until early 2013 and then
he moved on in 2012 or added to his
repertoire being a host and a head
writer at SourceFed really popular
spin-off show from philip defranco which
has just been incredibly popular and
probably I'd say my number one news
source when I'm talking about YouTube
news I do go to other sources for news
but what I want to news on YouTube I go
to SourceFed hey guys welcome to
SourceFed I'm Joe Bereta a new
classification of planets has emerged
changing the space game y'all 560
light-years away orbiting a star in the
Draco constellation is kepler-10c a new
type of planet known as a super earth
and I have all types of news to write
you're saying you don't use them as a
regular news source no I'm saying I do I
do you do that's what you're saying I'm
saying but they are my main youtube news
source but I'm telling not here they're
not my only news source you were saying
news about YouTube but what you were
saying was news on YouTube right yeah
okay it makes much like the way they do
News at SourceFed and a big reason is
because of the way that Joe thinks about
things but their news is not limited to
YouTube which'll signs in this it's all
kinds of news that's my point
you knew that I knew that and you
listening also know that so that I'm
clearing up confusion that no one had
yeah it was just all in your own brain
and I'm sincerely sorry for that mean
you don't have to apologize I remember
the first time we met Joe was on the way
to the YouTube live event in San
Francisco in 2008 otherwise known as
2008 now if this is the first time a
bunch of youtubers weekend together I
think we've talked about this on earlier
ear biscuits but I remember nudging you
like hey there's Moretti we read on it
at the airport yeah before we like went
down to baggage claim I was like that's
the guy from that's I see the brats a
Baretta didn't know who was who and
because I mean they were they were huge
that the them and Smosh were like the
huge comedic duo's on the Internet and
then there's us
yes aspiring comedic duo on YouTube so
it's like ah should we introduce her
side we had a chip on her shoulder I
mean I'll be I'll be perfectly honest
with you we've talked to Smosh and now
we've talked to to Joe but going back at
that time these guys were killing it as
a duo so obviously as a duo who was
trying to make it on YouTube they were
the standard it was like how do you get
to be as popular as these guys are and
how do you get to be as funny and to do
these things so there was definitely a
chip on my shoulder but so you certainly
don't go up and introduce yourself
that's not part of no coming one oh
because we didn't do yeah I was afraid
that he would be like well I got no idea
who you guys are right you know yeah
that was gonna you want to go there
that's really the fear it's but then
what happened was
we're hanging around the hotel and I'm
pretty sure Joe introduced himself or no
it was we had our picture taken with him
when we performed it like the outer
stage kind of thing yeah and it turns
out he he didn't know who we were and we
were very flattered and we took an epic
photo involving holding out coffee still
had the photo I remember a nice photo
stream
but it turns out that Joe is one of the
coolest guys that's what I thought then
it's like oh this is this is a great guy
you know someone that
on the Internet can actually be a nice
person to yeah I didn't know that could
happen
yeah he's become a good friend of ours
and I'm not just saying this he's one of
my favorite people on YouTube that I've
had the privilege to meet doing this job
and we had a great conversation with him
we got into talking about one of my
favorite things about Joseph fact that
he was in a DoubleDown commercial for
KFC and we got into that what it was
like and how it led to a nickname we
also talked about his deep-seated fear
of Chucky from child's play and how he
met Lou course we go into the whole
backstory of creating the dynamic duo
that actually quickly led to an NBC
pilot when we talk about his transition
into what he's doing now with SourceFed
and whether or not he sees himself as an
Internet news guy or a comedian yeah is
there and is there an identity crisis
going on there I don't know let's find
out link okay here it is our your
biscuit with Joe Bereta it's interesting
when you have to build something for a
baby and you you get to that point where
okay I'm doing step number three and I
feel like something might break yeah
because not only now are you in danger
of destroying something you've purchased
but there's always this question of what
I damaged it is it going to like stab my
kid three weeks from now a baby needs to
sleep tonight so I'm gonna finish it
from where I'm at but is he gonna wake
up right it's a sobering feeling yeah
that's not the first time I built a crib
I didn't but I'm not buying a crib for
Jackson we did pack and play with Hayden
for the longest time but I did buy a
crib for Hayden and my least favorite
memory of having a daughter was building
that thing it was the worst the only
picture that Heather has of me there's
two there's one of me trying to assemble
it and because I'm doing it by myself
and the second picture was just back to
the camera flipping the bird from behind
stop taking pictures
oh yeah the worst thing about assembling
things for your kids is because your
wife and probably your kids are watching
yeah so it's really it's embarrassing
but you don't want to admit it is
second-by-second a embarrassment testing
every
your manhood what you do things like
that the thing I noticed when I'm doing
something that feels very like
stereotypical dad like building
something for a baby I have this moment
where I stop and think I'm such a dad
right now uh-huh
you know like I could be this could be a
sitcom like I I'm a suit I am so
assuming that role right now I mean you
can't escape it it isn't like you I
should then stop and be like oh no I
don't want to be boxed in you just you
do type you put this crib together yeah
you know I'm not saying that but there's
just moments where you just I'm a dad I
I own a minivan I hear you want a
minivan how gross is that Heather
doesn't want one I'm like I've given up
let's get the minion what a minivan B
they got a little bit of get up and go
honey let's do it oh they got some power
it's got everything you are can you turn
this light every time I look at you it's
like looking into the Sun yeah we're
supposed to greatest halo everything you
want though you just did the perfect
mini Bank I'm not kidding this new link
drives the the old Honda Odyssey the new
one even my 10 year old knows he's like
dad the new Honda Odyssey has a vacuum
built into it really and that's enough
to get me thinking I'm so smart yeah
yeah it's got a vacuum built into it
it's amazing there's nothing you would
want more than that yeah I think about
how often you would use that it's nuts I
knew that I grew up or became a dad I
can't remember which one came first but
as when I was walking through Sears and
then one day it just clicked I didn't
want to look at anything but appliances
there's never like that before but it
was you know in commercials when they
you're about 23 24 you're that guy and
like the beer commercial that everything
slows down the music goes blue and you
look to your left and there's hot girls
walking by and it says yeah slow head
till that happened to me but it was like
a stackable washer and dryer
well the ironic thing is you've done the
slow head-tilt and not slow-mo in a beer
commercial like legitimately right I'm a
beer commercial guy I think I'm about
three or four years away from being
truck guy if I keep doing commercials
I'll just get truckin you're already
truck guy you're really vying for that
I'm very yes I'm the the resident vine
truck guy that knows nothing about drugs
but what which there I what what
commercial is it that you turned to the
camera and like you now wigs I contact
and nod slowly
that was my second beer commercial after
that the the contract on the first beer
commercial ran out and I was allowed to
do more beer commercials cuz that's all
I could just waiting yeah so I did we
got to get that guy that was Bud Light
and that was L my team scored now I'm
just gonna turn to the camera and just
mug like look right down the lens I was
talking to somebody about I don't even
know if the director wanted me to do
that but I was like you're getting me
looking down the lens and that's all
you're gonna get
then he had to use it before that it was
natural ice that was a whole nother
thing I just put them up on my website I
think like three weeks ago I just did
that if you guys are looking for those
little bits of my soul here they are
yeah and it was like for commercials
that I've done and I finally I think for
the first time tweeted out this Chevy's
Mexican restaurant commercial that I did
what was the first one that I landed I
was doing it trucks so I'm Mexican
restaurant in the back of a truck that's
amazing
could you imagine that's better than a
vacuum in a minivan so yeah I did that
and it's it's just a ridiculous
over-the-top I'm just screaming at
Mexican food and I'm like amazing that's
all I'm doing but when did you do that
one it was like five years ago when I
moved to LA was the first thing I did
okay and are we gonna talk about the
double down yeah we are then KFC Double
Down yeah it's back it is got it are you
you were in the original commercial in
the original a sandwich made the bread
was replaced there's no I read it was
done it was a replace but two chicken
breast fillets and chicken-fried chicken
breast in there not small you know how
most corners are eaten one yeah I saw
you he want
and I was like I gotta go on and it was
amazing overwhelming percent so are you
back for the sequel I'm not too bad
because commercial double down on the W
and money the cool thing about working
on a commercial for a new product is you
find out about this amazing thing way
before the public knows about it and you
got to be sworn to secrecy about it it's
when it's a double down how did you keep
your mouth shut because it was full is
the most amazing fast food creation top
ten most amazing one of the worst things
ever create I don't think right I don't
even for all those if you did you that
don't know what a double down is because
we haven't totally described it yet as
link started it's too deep fried chicken
breasts that replace the buns of the
chicken sandwich and then the insides
are bacon cheese and a concoction called
the kernel sauce is just a honey mustard
when it comes down to it mixed with the
kernels sweat and ashes it's so
disgusting deliciously disgusting like a
lifetime's amount of salt yeah it's so
bad that you you eat it I'm thirsty just
thinking yeah you eat it wrapped in a
it's like a wet not a wet towel but just
like plastic wrap why they invented
bread yeah it's so bad what did you do
in the commercial the commercial I think
I mean I was I I was just super excited
about the double down because we didn't
like bread I can't remember my lines but
I do know that the doctor the director
wasn't thinking because he gave the line
give me more chicken to the big black
guy and he screamed it I was like you
can't you know in the final cut yeah and
the thing is like and you were right
there you could have totally so I'm just
lookin like anybody could have said that
line sir but you gave it to that guy and
the other thing is that if you listen to
the commercial gosh this is what we're
talking about the Double Down I got a
lot of stories about you guys I got
another one after this the you hear our
voices are super high-pitched like I
love the double down and you would think
that they did that in post but they
didn't do it in post they didn't just
like up the pitch they made us suck down
which I'm pretty sure is a league
copious amounts of helium Oh every
single take you are joking not joking
like they would hand us the balloons in
the director would like kind of like to
look over his shoulder like I'm doing oh
[ __ ] here or something right like okay
does anybody know I'd suck this balloon
down we would suck down to three four I
was I literally was lightheaded and felt
the potential to pass out commercial
amazed right elbow down wasn't bad
enough for your health uh-huh and you
guys know wearing a massive helium
shortage you know we're about to run out
yeah using it in double dealt with our
shows finite amounts of helium and we're
sucking it down for a doubled anything
better captures the state of the world
right now is is that a director
somewhere is feeding helium to people to
advertise sandwiches that consist only
of two fried chicken breasts I mean
that's the world as we know it so yeah
that's the that's the story of the
double down and then it kind of went a
little bit farther in my life because
where I moved to when I first moved to
LA which is kind of where you guys are
then big Park there is where I used to
play basketball exam and it was with the
local ruffians and everybody had a
nickname but I never had a nickname I
never had a nickname growing up or
anything just in the part of the world
where we grew up it wasn't like New York
where you called some like a short round
or anything like that just a Beretta was
my nickname if I got one a lot of the
basketball players one day were just
like you're the dude from the DoubleDown
commercial and DoubleDown became a
basketball name and I'm super happy with
the fact that people called me Double
Down well it has an interesting sports
connotation mask I don't exactly know
what does that mean they're gonna you
double team you every time you get the
ball cuz that's a good loss 'm that
could just be a shirt there's gonna mean
hook or something yeah I thought that
worked as well yeah I don't know Joe I
appreciate you coming at this late hour
I'm trying to figure out what I mean
it's not that late it's like 7:30 but
what's your bedtime because with
SourceFed you you guys get up at the
butt crack of dawn because you're doing
news type stuff but you're your West
Coast in it so yeah I'm like live you
get up at 5:00 a.m. now and then I'm at
I'm almost 100% the first person there
because I'm the best employee there at
6:00 and then whatever I'm out and you
to where between 2:00 and 5:00 that is
not a Los Angeles no schedule you beat
the traffic though yeah that's the only
that's the reason I go that early or the
reason I push for it it saves me
probably an hour and a half of drive
time of day so what time you go to bed
of a night that's where I'm a bad person
because it's 12:00 oh well sometimes one
you know you don't want your life to be
work you don't want your life to be just
work hang out with the kids put them to
bed go to bed I mean you want to hang
out the wife you want to watch some TV
you want to troll the alleys of LA and
look for you know whatever kind of
fights you can get into knife gun yeah
back-alley wrestling matches and it's
double down so yeah I mean my average
five hours of sleep it's someday that's
gonna come back and get me it probably
will probably you're one of those guys I
can can be normal with five hours
normally I don't know if you guys watch
SourceFed yes we do it's not I wouldn't
say normal it's a but how do we describe
it it's like SourceFed is I've described
it as and this is too much of a
compliment for what we do it's the Jon
Stewart Show had intercourse made sweet
love to en tur tainment and they had a
baby and then they handed us that baby
and we dropped it on its head that's
kind of what I think SourceFed but it's
but it it's still living yeah I mean
it's getting by it's just it's different
yeah yeah yeah so let's go back to baby
Beretta yeah yeah speaking of a baby
that was dropped on its head multiple
times where were you born I was born in
Whitefish Montana but I grew up in
Columbia Falls Montana which are around
Kalispell Montana which is basically the
front door of Glacier National Park in
the northwest corner of Montana so did
you when you grow up on the front
doorstep of a national park
does that make you automatically you're
like really granola
I like you'd pop out of the womb with
like one of those hiking sticks some I
would say for some yes for me it didn't
quite get me like that I did a lot of
outdoor stuff a lot of camping hiking
and whatnot it didn't the bug didn't
infect me as a as much as it did other
people because a lot of the
misconception about Montana is that it's
either not either but a lot of people
think hick cowboy bull riding that type
of culture and there is that there but
especially in the northwest it's more of
that it like outdoorsy North Face
granola II as you said and there's
there's a lot of that but I kind of like
rode the thin lines more of a jock
growing up to a lot of sports but
Glacier Park is something that I did
with the family a lot I did more getting
into high school but didn't totally
appreciate and tell of course I was
going but now only every time I go back
that's where I like to hang out what's
your family situation you had you got
like younger siblings right I've got an
older brother a and a younger brother
and sister they're twins twins and their
only a year behind me so okay it's kind
of the three of us well cluster there
yeah you don't know how my parents did
it I couldn't even could I mean you guys
never had twins no imagine having twins
no doctor would give one back I'd leave
right yeah donate it I'd pick the
better-looking one and ya know I mean
it's like look I've got a spare oh great
that's another way is he in it yeah is
this one and he went grew up to be a
politician and the other one I dropped
on its head and it became SourceFed Yeah
right there you go so I remember hearing
this story I think this was on a table
talk where you told about me I guess it
was your worst fear the one about going
in a haunted house oh yes your younger
twin siblings loved the haunted house
even though you were older you were
deathly afraid of it yeah and your so
you insisted on going in with your mom
yes I my brother and sister that I was
probably seven let's say so they were
six to me and this isn't this is my way
of getting at the psychological profile
of Joe as a kid it's kind of what I'm
after here
the reason I was so deathly afraid of
things to even backtrack a little bit
more is because my parents made a
mistake and I don't even know how it
ended up happening but I saw child's
play when I was really young Chucky
one of the most frightening things ever
and I became I had night terrors for
like four years after that Wow a lot of
sleepwalking like would wake up in the
because of child's play because John's
play just messed me up mentally it
wasn't it was a doll that killed people
friended the little boy and earned his
trust and then he turned on him so it
wasn't even just the killing it was a
betrayal of trust and a freaking doll
anyways I would have nightmares
legitimately messed you I messed me up
for years yeah I have I have very vivid
memories of some of the nightmares that
I had about that damn doll Wow but I was
so messed up in my sleep state that I
would I would in the middle of the night
sleep walk downstairs and you guys have
kids have you ever seen them
sleepwalking no sleep talking a lot but
no walking so I hate in the slept walk
once Hayden's my daughter and the other
the other one Jesus Jackson is too young
to further that to have happened but
she's slept walk once and she's talked
in her sleep a lot when they talk in
their sleep it's creepy it's not cute
ever you think of to say the cutest
thing but I'm like you don't know you're
a different person right now and I don't
know you I don't know if I should wake
you up cuz that would mess you up it is
scary it's weird it's creepy but when
they're walking and doing it's even
creepier but I would like I have this
blank look on my face I guess and I
would just casually walk down the stairs
in my sleep turn to my father and then
like take a sprint Adam jump on his lap
grab his shirt and scream I don't want
you to die in his face now imagine your
kiss Oh to you that's what that movie
did to me now I love it I'm a horror nut
now it's really yeah like my teenage
years it kind of clicked and I was like
oh wait they're okay now she's just
accept this yeah it's the subconscious
love it's my favorite genre without me
even realizing if you dealt with this
with your parents like hey I don't
remember you don't know how you got
accidentally an accidental viewing I
don't know if it was for I don't know I
honestly don't know what happened it
might have been a babysitter because I
watched horror movies with my mom but it
wasn't that it you know I watch
Hellraiser probably when I was in middle
school you can maybe handle that's
pretty good that's some heavy stuff for
raising middle school yeah right yeah
that's that I was
like yeah I was very influential in the
mine spot still growing and making
connections with my synapses so that
explains why you so that you had to go
in the haunted house cuz your younger
siblings did it yeah but you had to get
your mom to hold your hand yeah so they
would eat it all the time and I never
wanted to go into the haunted house but
this time I just said you know what I
want to grow as a person it's time to
learn some new skills like going through
haunted houses with my mother because
they would always come out laughing and
having like her as if if they had the
best time in their life so it's like I'm
going but you have to hold my hand mom
she's like fine so the my little brother
and sister going first and then my mom
and I walk in and you guys have been to
those fair honored houses they're not
real haunted houses you know they're on
the back of a truck they get driven
around and you step on something and
they make a sound so we stepped on
they're mostly haunted not actually
they're programmed to be haunted we
slept on one of the little pads and boom
it makes that sound and I freaked out
and the first thing I do is I just
instinctively bite my mom on the butt I
open my mouth and I go and I'm making
that sound and I didn't let go of the
clench until we made it all the way out
on the other side so imagine and I was
it wasn't like a light clench it was
like she probably had to be testing your
hands I don't know I mean I was probably
grabbing across somewhere else I mean
you know so she might say strike me off
more things are jumping I'm clenching
harder and we finally get out and I
don't think I don't think she ever won
huh that's only again Wow so yeah that's
the story of me biting my mom's butt for
an extended 10 minutes so were you an
introverted child or was it just you
were just afraid of Chucky I think I was
always a silly child I like to have fun
and I was around bumptious but I've
always and I still kind of am slightly
introverted in the sense of when I meet
new people and I'm kind of quiet until I
get to know somebody hmm um not like
rudely quiet like that's a weird guy
quiet but I've never been the first to
go up to a girl and talk to her for the
first time or be the first one to make
jokes in a crowd and I need a little bit
of one-on-one time I like to feel people
out because I'll probably say something
that I'll wear my foot should be long in
my mouth and I need to know that I'm
around the type of people where they
don't mind that type of humor
so rented the performer bug start to
bite the performer bug my senior year in
high school we found a camera and some
editing equipment we started making
videos before the world of YouTube and
stuff like that sure there was a class I
think I wasn't taking you but my friends
were it was called it was just one of
those bullcrap classes called I think it
was pop culture is literally what it was
called and they talked about like a high
school elective yeah that's exactly what
it was culture still on my yeah and one
of the the assignments and that was go
make some commercials or something like
that so we've got a camera got the
editing equipment early early final cut
you know when that was first coming out
yeah and we just made a bunch of just
dumb videos I mean it was the type of
stuff that we probably would have made
and put on YouTube if YouTube was around
at the time but it wasn't so that's kind
of when it started and then I went off
to college and because we didn't have
drama in high school and Columbia Falls
at the time and something that I was
always interested in but couldn't do it
so go just do a bunch of sports that's
all I did like five a year and five a
year yeah football wrestling basketball
track baseball and that was it yeah
that's the fight and okay so eating you
didn't count cheerleading as a sport
I didn't cheerlead in high school okay
oh oh I went to college without any
plans I just went to Gonzaga and and how
did you how did you choose Gonzaga
Gonzaga I chose because they gave me
money my college search was pathetic
I found that filling out and nobody
should do what I'm about to say I didn't
I didn't like filling out all the essays
and stuff I was like this is more
homework this is like homework for my
future I don't want to do that stupid
decision didn't look around enough I had
a couple colleges offer me I had one
football scholarship I had a track
scholarship small schools one in North
Montana and then Gonzaga I knew was a
good school I knew about Gonzaga because
of their basketball team and they were
everybody in the northwest was like
Gonzaga is the best turns out it was a
good school and I liked that they gave
me good money not good enough as it
turns out school that's not always fun
but you got like a partial academic
scholarship scholarship yeah there
weren't just a jock you were smart too
you may have graduated second in my
class okay well your overachiever
I knew Jill was smart don't act
surprised oh I don't well he was smart
but applied school smart as it is it is
a different facet of smartness you seem
in that Bud Light Commercial hey that
dude is smart he told me to turn to the
camera and I did on cue so I want to
Gonzaga for whatever reason and it
turned out was a great choice I loved it
and the thing that I was most into
watching on TV at the time was whose
line is it anyway I loved it I thought
was amazing Colin Mochrie and Ryan
Stiles were comedy gods to me I didn't
know improv was the thing that people
could do and then turns out there was an
improv troupe at Gonzaga and I was a
resident assistant again to save money
as a horrible Resident Assistant good
Lord as the worst RA the worst as in the
best I let my guys do whatever they
wanted
the freshman SS often as a sophomore
right yeah and then one of my one of my
residents was part of it I was I you
know as we did that thing where you talk
about it in hopes that maybe they invite
you oh you do that improv thing huh
that's pretty cool how does like to
judge you how did you get into it was
like not that I want to and then he
invited me I went to it and then I got
into improv and that's kind of how
everything started that got me
performing I started doing plays I did
Pippin
I did dead man walking I was Matthew
Poncelet in that and that I guess
opposed the moment that the rest of the
future started to get paved at that
moment it was that's where I met Luke
brats and that's when we started making
videos but what about the cheerleading
cheerleading was we want to know about
the cheerleading went to Gonzaga again
without much of a plan I was thinking
maybe teaching maybe being a physical
therapist and I
I didn't I didn't research things I
didn't know what my path was gonna be I
mean I went there as a blank slate open
to anything and then my RA at the time
was this massive black guy from Hawaii's
name was a little Mont huge he was like
I wanted to connect with my Ras I've
never met anybody like you like hey man
I see that you do the the cheer team
over there that's pretty cool
you never met a black person before well
from Montana I mean is that is that
really what's going on I didn't grow up
with really there was a couple Filipino
people in our town but we had one black
guy in Columbia Falls when I was growing
up and his name was Ray and I remember
he worked at the local mill and I'm
pretty sure he was referred to as Ray
the black guy not like a racist censor
just like as a designation he was just
this that was the one that we had in the
town incredibly nice guy I think his son
ended up being like a record-breaking
runner Derek really good game but you
got to know Lamont
I got your re this guy's fascinates like
seven tangents in high school I did
cheerlead once they sometimes they
recruit like football players to go do a
halftime show at like a basketball game
or something I mean you're wearing
makeup no just like through the girls
like I'm not safe at all there's like
hey will you come girls for a while so
we did that and then I walked up to my
cell you do that your leader thing is
like I did cheerleading in high school
for a halftime show once and he's like
you should come tryout we're looking for
people and I was like okay well what the
heck I'll go do it he suggested it I
went there I did the the tryouts just to
see what it was like because he's not
even the tryouts I went I went to go
check it out for one day just to see
what it was all about and then we did it
I was like okay this isn't really my bag
and then I left and then turned out he
made me come on the one night that was
the last night of tryouts and the reason
he was asking people to go is because
they didn't have enough people and I was
the last guy that filled that filled the
team so I was the eighth guy that would
have been the eighth for the eighth girl
yes I did you onto the team that was
later so I'm sitting there playing Tony
Hawk pro ski
in my dorm room with all of the the kids
on my level of the dorm we're just
hanging out into my room and we're like
hey we're getting to know each other
we're growing out and like I'm Joe I'm
Justin my name is time we're hanging out
and having a good time and then all of a
sudden boom a door flies open there's
confetti there silly string there
streamers and they all yell they're in
their cheerleader uniforms so I just ran
out with them and then I was on the team
because at that point I did feel I would
feel so bad just ditching this poor girl
that all she wanted to do was be a
cheerleader and I will say that I it's
one of the most numb is miserable I
didn't like it at all it was not fun I
continued with it because Gonzaga was
supposed to go really far in the NCAA
tournament and I was gonna get to go
everywhere for free yeah great seats
sweet front-row tickets to the Final
Four Dan Ditka our point guard he's
all-american we're gonna go so far we
lose to Wyoming in the first round in
Albuquerque New Mexico it's like the
biggest letdown ever met a little bunch
of good guys on the team I wouldn't
change it for that I got a girlfriend
out of it and a girl that you were
picking up no it was a different one
touching on one but let's talk about
that because you pick the woman up by
the by the rear well you pick her up by
the hips if you want to get technical
thank you so we're on just tell me about
what's going through your mouth when it
happens don't drop her that's it like
that whole like like masculine perverted
side of it all is thrown out the window
the first time you throws up a human
being in the air and you're like oh
you're like okay catch you this is what
this is about this is about survival
this isn't about an advanced actually
the best thing that probably came out of
it other than a couple friends whose
weddings I've went to and whatnot and I
keep in touch with is that I went to
college with a ear ring and I it was
just a single earring I was one of those
guys I'm gonna get it only in one
because this is how I'm just gonna I'm
gonna stand out and do something
different so I did that and it was so
stupid and it was infected and
constantly looked dumb and I had it and
then in one of the practices one of the
girls was following that we're supposed
to catch and her hand grabbed the
earring and
did out oh so it was meant to be it made
a better decision for my life than I
could make for myself Cheerilee right
forced you to lose in here yeah
so that side was that trajectory fizzled
out but you met Luke I met Luke during
in improv and guts Gonzaga University
Theatre sports and is this a type of
thing that you guys were like you guys
were instant best friends type thing or
what was the what was the situation with
Luke and I we he was a freshman and I
was a sophomore and I didn't start until
the end of my sophomore year but I
remember we both were just kind of like
I like how that guy does funny and
vice-versa we both were thinking about
that about each other and then the next
year I became that's when I was like
what am I gonna do with my lab I'll be a
broadcasting major and then one of the
things that I needed to do in
broadcasting was create television shows
it was mostly news journalism it's kind
of what the program focused on but you
could do other things in me and this
other guy Ben malikan who also did a
comedy website for a while really funny
guy were the only two that wanted to do
the comedy show while the other 40
people in the program went and did just
these the news stuff which I had no
interest in hmm and we just need to make
videos so I was like Luke let's go make
some videos and then we made some videos
so at most of the really barats and
bereta stuff that's on our site ninja
rap the Mormon missionaries Aaron Pitino
that one's been lost to time I had like
the first five six seven videos Gonzaga
Ras some other stuff that we've taken
out those were videos that I got graded
on and we just threw up on our early
website which was just a place where we
hosted QuickTime videos because again it
was before YouTube yeah I got a little
bit of a following there and then
YouTube came and we were like oh great
this is cool our parents can watch our
stuff now because I can't figure out how
to do anything else online through it on
YouTube made Mother's Day and Mother's
Day blew up so Mother's Day was a class
assignment still Mother's Day was the
like the first video after I graduated I
think I was working at a commercial
production company in Spokane Luke was
still in school and we made that video
and we threw up on YouTube and that's
the one that blew up but we all we had
this back
the video so right oh wait these guys
made a really funny video that's that's
climbing the YouTube charts but they've
got all this other stuff and I think
that's what helped us out so yeah cuz
you were kind of a in it to you or a
brand you guys had done all of these
videos quantify this thing blowing up I
mean at the time blowing up back in the
day was a little bit different than
blowing up these days I mean what see
what's considered blowing up now is a
million hits on a video even good
anymore I don't know I don't think it's
blowing up yeah you know which is crazy
this yeah it's probably like 10 million
really yeah so we would monitor our our
stats on our crappy little home page
brats and Bretta calm and we would
probably get 200 if a good day 2,000
hits a day we woke up on Mother's Day or
the day before or something like that we
think we posted it the week before
Mother's Day and we had 40,000 hits on
our website what happened you know that
was even before you realized that
YouTube could get you traction yeah and
what happened is that our video got
featured on the front page of YouTube
and this was back when the front page
well someone made an editorial decision
to put you there and it was one video
the front page on YouTube back in the
day was you can go to youtube.com and
what would come up I think is the logo
and then a featured video and that was
it and that was our video so brats and
beretta comm we were smart enough to put
our website at the end of it start a
branding for us and that's how it kind
of blew up and we were like what is
what's happening figured it out and like
this is this is good and then we started
getting phone calls and it was crazy
when they yeah there's this back catalog
of videos which is it that's is this is
a different story then you know you hear
from a lot of people which is we made a
video it blew up and we immediately
thought what are we gonna do let's start
making more videos so what was the if
there was no business plan so to speak
in that what was the thought oh we've
got all these videos were did you guys
want to go around and do live comedy
shows like what did you hope that's
translated in I I don't think we knew I
don't think anybody knew back then yeah
cuz again I was working at a commercial
production company I was editing I was
an editor I would occasionally write us
a commercial I would create occasionally
direct a commercial as that was kind of
what I was
at the time and all we knew is that we
liked making videos so we kept making
videos and really it wasn't even just
about videos as it was about comedy so I
joined comedy Sportz in Spokane which
was the professional company there for
improv and I still do that here in LA
one of my favorite things to do and then
he continued doing theater and and
comedy at Gonzaga and then even during
that time we joined we created a
stand-up comedy show we want a stand up
comedy competition so we're always doing
comedy together yeah and the the videos
were just another outlet for that so it
wasn't like this is so huge we got to
keep doing it it was just like this is
so cool let's keep making videos in our
free time because that's what we like to
do and so and you weren't making money
off of the video in otherwise this
program oh god we were so stupid about
that when the partner program started we
were like nobody's ever gonna buy into
this I think we would didn't join the
partner crime program until like two
years after it was done what a waste
good lord good god so stupid anyway like
no foresight whatsoever so dumb so we
kept making videos and then Luke
graduated and we he ended up working at
the company with me and we would in our
downtime at the company we'd still make
videos we ended up making cubicle wars
was actually it was a legit commercial
that we did for a company windward
reports that just gave us a little bit
of cash allowed us to do what we want
like the smartest type of sponsor here's
money put our name at the end that's it
we got to make cubicle wars and we win
side away I think that was the first
video ever favorited on our channel oh
really I remember that video way back in
the day so it must have been oh here's a
new button
it's called favorite yeah right and
that's the video that I mean that's one
of the first youtube videos i remember
watching and i mean we were trying to
we're trying to do our thing we had
videos on our website and eventually on
youtube - i can't remember exactly how
it worked out but i mean we would watch
you guys and it would be like threat or
these guys are great this is the goal
yeah this is the goal I think it was
very much a
I remember looking at your channel and
seeing 65,000 subscribers which has at
the time I can't think of anyone who had
I mean that was the top you know there
was maybe somebody had 70 or whatever
eek was I think we were the third most
subscribed in the early the early
run-ins right I just never looking at
the number in thinking not in comedy
overall yeah yeah I was just like how
how does that happen you know I like how
how you get that many people interested
in your gun I didn't even know again we
didn't realize what was going we would
have capitalized on everything I think a
lot better you know if we knew then what
we know now it was I think it was like
broker's was number one yeah open like
geriatric that guy that just died uh and
then us and then Smosh was right behind
us Boheme okay yeah
that's cool stuff so yeah and you guys
had a number of videos that were you you
were played Mormon missionaries or there
was like a Bible thing
so I guess early on I assumed okay the
this is this is a Mormon comedy duo
because they know this stuff yeah and
that's kind of where they're coming from
like what was the perspective there was
it
oh we just coming from like your
background people you grew up with or
just Luke have experienced religious
knowledge definitely came from Luke I'm
not I can't speak for him saying if he
was like super religious growing up or
not but he just had the knowledge Luke's
one of the smartest guys that I know or
I've ever met hands down and he just
knew that stuff the Bible in a minute he
just showed up one day and he was like
hey I wrote this rhyming rap about the
Bible like in five minutes last night
and so you didn't from the whole
spiritual side of things or like the
biblical or if it was the Mormon thing
you're like okay that's not my bag this
is a good idea it's gonna be funny I'm
going along with it what was your point
of Rev yeah cuz I don't think we ever
made fun never made fun of religion we
just kind of utilized it as a vehicle we
never like I don't think we ever pointed
fingers and and said you're you're
stupid for believing something or or
you're funny for believing something we
just kind of
we did the Wesley Christ which was Jesus
is partying the other we did the Mormon
missionaries I think I just was like hey
Luke I got this idea I wanted
we just improv in front of a door that
keeps opening up and that's how that
video came to be ahead and most I mean
none of that like not none of it but a
lot of it wasn't written it was just us
messing around with a camera open a door
say some things yeah I mean it
everything was free game for us but I
don't think we were ever malicious with
our comedy yes I think made it palatable
for most people and like you thought we
were Mormon like a Mormon comedy duo so
it was either that is it are you guys
Mormons are you guys brothers or you
guys you know together we had a t-shirt
when we first started out it was the the
the male symbol for the bathroom
so just leo the white guy just standing
there and we had two of them standing
next to each other you know in a box
that said brothers under it and then or
and then there was another box with the
same two bathroom symbols just holding
hands lovers it was brothers or lovers
brats and Bretta compromise embraced it
so it was good I mean yeah we just
YouTube was really good to us at the
start the Mother's Day was featured and
then our completely uncalled-for video
was featured and then I think was the
Wesley video was featured and so was
wind reports I think those were our four
and that you know helped us all to raise
yeah so when did when did Hollywood
start calling after Mother's Day it was
it was pretty quick Mother's Day came
out and maybe let's say a month later or
whatever after me releasing a couple
more videos we got a call from a manager
in Hollywood that was like hey I'm a
manager in Hollywood but his voice was
like this right yeah no he's really
young he was a real go-getter
I want to manage you guys were like
you're in Hollywood what are you gonna
do for us we're in Spokane Washington
he's like I'll make things work and he
did he worked really hard for us and
both his name Dan Farah and he's
actually Tony danza's manager now which
is interesting yeah so yeah so he called
us and we're like cool you
can be our manager didn't expect to hear
anything cuz we figured if he's gonna
find any work for us it was gonna be in
LA and he's not gonna find any work for
to span Spokane possible Mormon comedy
duo boys a week after that CAA in LA
which is at one of the big agencies down
here they wrote us an email or like we
want to rep you and we're like what's
the CAA somebody informed us they're
like you have to alright they're not
gonna find us any work it doesn't matter
and then we luckily had a manager and an
agency in on our team because a week
after that NBC sent us an email it was
literally one line that was like hey
we're NBC we want you guys to do a pilot
I go okay okay NBC fake account guys but
they did and we got to that's that's how
happened then we had the team in place
they got us a good deal and we wrote a
sketch comedy pilot and got to shoot it
and direct it and edit it and called
this as cold a sack it was really fun
learned a lot so it was a 22 minute
pilot yeah a little longer this is
called a sack and you guys were the
stars yeah we did everything you did
everything the only thing that we did
not do was press record on the camera
they got us a really good DP okay his
name was Greg he was something he was
amazing
and there was a development deal
associated that right so it was it was
it we're painting you guys to make a
pilot or we're paying you guys to kind
of lock you up to whatever it is we're
gonna we want to work with you guys I
don't think we got the lock-up deal what
does that call to forget I don't know
yeah first look or yeah people do that
they'll be like I know Jimmy Fallon was
like locked up with NBC for the longest
time like he couldn't go do other pilots
because they were like if you're gonna
do something we're gonna give you a lot
of money and someday he'll do it for us
good what it's called
no they paid us to they wanted to make
an edgy hip alternative comedy hour is
what NBC wanted to do at the time so it
was us and they planned on combining us
the second half an hour supposed to be
Improv Everywhere yeah yeah Sara Lee
Todd yeah so they were gonna we were
gonna do our sketch thing and they were
gonna do the the live comedy stuff out
in the real world and I can't remember
if they got a show or not they didn't on
NBC I think they did somewhere else
maybe IFC
I don't remember I don't know if ever
became a TV show but anyway so we got to
they said do whatever you want and we're
like well we know how to make sketch
comedy so we made sketch comedy and the
show like I said was called this is
called a sack and was about two guys
that lived in a town and we played all
the quirky characters in the town so
that we brought the Mormon missionaries
into the show they rapped and we
released a couple of these mailman
versus milkman which is on our channel
that was part of it right yeah it was
just this daily look inside of this town
called called a sack and you would see
the construction workers do something
and then the mailman and the milkman and
then the missionaries and it would have
been different characters every single
episode played by us hopefully guest
stars as it went on I think the concept
is actually pretty good and I think
there's a show called Little Britain
that kind of did something similar over
in England and but it was all on
location and when it comes to sketch
comedy that doesn't make a lot of sense
no it would have been an expensive show
and I don't think you take a chance on
somebody especially when on a show like
that which is sketch which would have
existed on the same network that already
has the the pinnacle of sketch shows
which is Saturday Night Live right and I
mean the Lonely Island had their version
of the same thing which I think was
after you guys called us awesome John
yeah
which was kind of they post it on the
YouTube channel yeah I'm trying to
remember what I just remembered the
opening because it was great along with
kind of a thing but they posted their
whole pilot you I mean once the thing
kind of didn't happen you took some of
the clips and put them on your channel
yeah I think I think the Lonely Island
was smart and made a deal where they
were like well we have an online
following if it doesn't happen can we
put it on there or maybe they financed
the whole thing and they got to put it
on there no matter what so what happened
with that with you guys did that was
that in retrospect what was it some
money in your pocket then the whole
experience yeah was it a diversion from
creating on YouTube yes I would say that
or MySpace there was a little bit of
that we it was a definite version
because we were we were on the uptake
like I said we were in the top
ten three three for a while but like we
were up there for the longest time
mm-hmm and then we again we didn't know
that YouTube game nobody did back then
but a consistent content was important
back then and we stopped doing
consistent content because we were off
doing a pilot I think we didn't post an
original video for eight months or
something like that but we're running
around mm-hmm and I think that kind of
stunted our growth and I didn't stop us
from doing videos but I think it
hindered us a little bit as far as you
know staying in the upper ranks but we
have always had a very devote following
devout following so that wasn't a huge
problem and then the myspace deal came
around that was great
because that was we're gonna pay you a
lot of money to post one video a month
on MySpace and we're like well can we
put in there that we get to keep the
rights to all our videos and like sure
and we're like could you mind if we try
to also put those videos on YouTube
three weeks after we put them on MySpace
and they're like sure I think this is
the best deal ever yeah so we got paid
pretty good money to do the myspace deal
I was right before myspace died
we killed myspace and I think they were
trying to they were trying to save
themselves and by doing that they were
making outrageous deals with content
creators and we were one of them thank
God and again that was another thing
where we were still producing for
YouTube but then even then the YouTube
world was was formula forming itself and
one of the things was you don't go off a
YouTube even if you're gonna put videos
on YouTube we're gonna be really angry
at you so we even lost I think a little
bit of the fan base for going to myspace
first and then putting the videos on
YouTube so when I don't think we ever
played the YouTube game correctly but
YouTube has always been great to us it
was such a weird way to put it we've
never put a good business plan in
practice for YouTube because making
videos for us was always it was always
the extra thing we did we always had
another job or hmmm or it was just a
free time thing in the story at the
beginning and yeah I mean we've never
been a consistent poster on on the site
but we've always had a really good
following but you can't really complain
and be interesting too
to see what would happen if we found a
business plan or a life plan at this
point because that's the age group were
in so right yeah at what point did you
move here in this process the mainland
I'm curious like when the SourceFed
thing kind of came in kind of from left
field I don't know if you characterize
that it was the middle of the myspace
era moved to LA yeah so we were getting
a good enough paycheck from my space
where we could up and move and we upped
and moved and got our mind blown about
how expensive the city is it's
outrageous and the the the my space
money kept us afloat for quite a while
and then that ran out and it was just
odd for me because I have a family
it became odd jobs after that it's like
I said we're still doing videos Luke and
I whenever we can but I have to go be a
bartender here and then it became I need
to be a waiter and then I was like I was
serving pancakes to the Jeff Goldblum
and friends for God it was probably a
year and a half or two so literally
serve pancakes to Jeff Gillooly
served pancakes to Jeff Goldblum and his
random super-young different girl that
he brought in every day oh it was his
hangout which were at restaurant the
griddle cafe and were you like on a
first name basis with him no but he did
say I look like Aaron Eckhart no that
cool thanks Jeff Goldblum loved Jurassic
Park What did he say I said give me my
oatmeal no brown sugar
I am ziering would show up every once in
a while I can see that now you I know
yeah yeah good-looking guy very still
looks like I am ziering still does in it
and about this time is when the kind of
the SourceFed opportunity happened yeah
so I'm serving pancakes but I'm also at
my wit's end the place was very good to
me I've got no qualms about it it's a
good job maybe good enough money for
what I needed to do at the time while we
were making brats bready videos
sporadically but I needed what was going
through my mind when the SourceFed
opportunity came about was I need to
take a life risk I need to do something
different otherwise what am i doing and
then I heard about SourceFed and I just
went an audition for it I want then you
know I was like this is going to be
something different I feel
a little weird about it because it's in
the YouTube realm but I need to take a
risk I need to take a chance and then
thankfully it worked out
you felt weird about it because it's in
a YouTube run what do you mean well it
you feel loyal to the thing that you're
doing on the platform that you're doing
it so brats and bread is the thing like
I was like well should I do this because
I'm barats and bereta if I'm on YouTube
that's what I'm doing but again it
wasn't Bratz bread it wasn't my job it's
always been like the thing that if it
could make us money great I would do it
but at the time I'm it's either I do
Brad some bread and serve pancakes or I
do Brad some beretta and I do source
fenton which is in the realm of the
things that I'm doing so was there a
perception I mean as a as a comedian as
a sketch comedian with the background
that you had what what reservations did
you have about getting involved with the
format a news format you knew you knew
you were gonna get to be funny it wasn't
like oh this is unfunny straight-laced
news but did you have reservations about
the format and if so what were they I
don't think I did I I wanted to try
something different because what I was
doing wasn't working I was a I was a
married man or dad wasn't quite married
yet but we're essentially as an
essentially a married man with a kid and
I was serving pancakes at 28 and I
didn't want to be that guy anymore so I
was willing to try anything new and I
knew it was in the realm of YouTube and
it was something that I could hopefully
if it was successful week I could build
my own brand as well as help build the
brats and Brad Baretta brand as well as
just trying new different things at the
same time so I didn't mind the format
but even going into it they I don't
think the format was really nailed down
and we got to kind of create that with
our voices which was nice
me and Elliot and and Lee and I think we
created something kind of fun and
different which was nice right now going
into it
what was your did you know Phil and what
was your perception of him and and how
has that changed since working for him
Phil and I were I think we just kind of
we always just knew of each other's
existence like he we we met each other I
think for the first time at first time I
met you guys
that's right I'm so disappointed there
hasn't been another YouTube laugh
because I had a blast there's a big ol
waste of money but I have blast yeah it
was good it's fun I'm at MC Hammer
amazing it's seven years 2006 I still
have that hat eight years yeah hey
that's crazy
it was such a good time we stock Katy
Perry before she was Katy Perry yeah we
did
that's right she molested bo burnham on
stage it's great
he was like 50 so ya know I knew I knew
of what Phil I knew Phil I knew what he
did and I think vice versa and I think
he heard that I wanted to do SourceFed I
was like cool I know what Joe does and
he wanted to ring me on and it kind of
worked out in in that sense and then
what's your title over there I'm the
head writer what does that mean that
means I like ribs is that are you like
dad over there
I've heard you're like Joe's like the
dad he's in charge really he's in charge
of SourceFed we've had different
timelines of what my level of power is
there but yeah as the head writer I help
choose the stories or they basically
pitch them to me and if it sounds like
it's a stinker I'll say we should
probably find something else that's it
but everybody has free voice they'll
read me their script and if I have a
joke that I can help punch him up I'll
do it and five months ago to a year back
a year prior to that I would also watch
down final edits but we've since put a
brought on a producer that now does the
final watch downs for videos and stuff
so I don't have to worry about that so
yeah and so Elliott's gone and I know
Meg's gone there's other people coming
there's a lot of fresh faces type of
thing are you
moving more kind of behind the scenes or
are you doing the same amount of videos
I was just curious know it's pretty much
the same we have a couple part-timers
now Matt will and Rayna they've kind of
come in and and are picking up some of
the slack after Megan Elliot
went off to go do their own thing but I
would say my workload is still the same
was that a good good decision for them
for Elliot for Meg what was the deal
there I think they both just were ready
to go try something new you know
before joining SourceFed I wanted I
needed to take a risk to find
inspiration and passion again and I
think for them they needed to just try
something different I mean we've been
doing it for two and a half years now
it's a long time to do anything in the
realm of YouTube even let alone
entertainment you know yeah well and it
seems like you've got kind of a you know
you come in from a background of having
something that was everybody knew about
on YouTube with Bratz and Bretta and
then that kind of losing momentum in a
certain way where you had to have a
second job moving into something that
now is also a really popular entity
you're part of something different it's
a different story than than what they
have where they really nobody knew they
weren't from the youth from YouTube now
they've kind of built a career they can
kind of maybe go try something on their
own for you having had that and now
having what you have with SourceFed
being a part of something like this
do you have less of that desire to be
like yeah maybe someday I do want to go
back and and try to make the breath and
bread a thing or the Joe Bereta thing
happen in a big way or you just could
you know how you feel about where you're
at right yeah I'm super passionate about
all three things I've got I've got a lot
of pride for SourceFed because I do feel
like a lot of it is something that I
created out of or helped create out of
you know my hard work compassion in my
vision and I only want to see it succeed
and I want to be there as it succeeds
but there's also the the creator
independent Joe that's inside of what
I'm doing right now that for the first
time where am i I'm now starting to
figure out maybe what I want to do with
my own personal brand because all of my
endeavors have been with somebody else
or connected to somebody else and now I
want to find the time to also build the
Joe Bereta vision whatever that is I
can't say what it is but I'm finally
taking steps to make that happen while
continuing to do SourceFed so I started
Joe Bereta calm where I'm doing a little
bit of writing and stuff and posting all
the daily or weekly
happenings of things that I do on the
internet or in Hollywood and then I
started my own YouTube channel
finally with nothing on it except for my
vine compilations right now because
that's just a time thing and then
Bratton beretta is definitely something
that I've I'll I def want to put more
time and effort into and once I have
that opportunity it's something that I
would love to build just because I don't
think Peter I have yet to see something
where two guys are doing what Luke and I
did I feel like I go back and watch our
videos and they still make me laugh and
sometimes I forget that we did some
funny stuff and I'll get I'll get caught
up watching the videos with my daughter
and I'll be like damn it damn it I like
a lot of the reason what we didn't
capitalize on is just because you know I
did have to have a job and do other
things and if I had that opportunity to
put more time and effort into it I think
we could do some pretty cool stuff
so where's Luke at on this I think if
he's just example I wanna do it no no
definitely me that's hundred percent me
so you're the problem
I mean you your commitment the source
fetes is so involved my commitment to
just like needing to feed my family
yeah but the SourceFed does take a lot
of time up but I don't think that's an
excuse for not continuing to make
content over amber add some Beretta I
was just uh you know you're up at five
in the morning you're home at four
you're tired yeah got it spend the
weekends a little bit and we like we had
a couple videos here and there but again
never consistently enough to parlay that
into something bigger so do you guys you
guys talk about that I mean like how
does that work what's the dynamic as you
talk about the status of Brad Brad the
other that's the other thing about the
way we've always worked is that it's
always just kind of there was never a we
would never just sit down and create it
be like I got an idea
I got an idea we would email them back
and forth and stuff and then we get
together and make it like it was our our
system of creation never really had us
in the same place at the same time
having those type of conversations but
we wouldn't when we did get together we
would make live shows that were like 45
minute live shows that we've we've done
tours for comedy at colleges and stuff
we make good
stuff together it just comes down to
what is the what is the reality where
you both can make a living while making
content and that reality is getting
harder and harder to grasp yeah as we're
getting older especially with me having
two kids and what is he doing he writes
for a bunch of a bunch of channels he's
and if he's not writing for other people
he's writing for himself he's got a
channel too that's really good he's done
a lot of funny stuff on it brats
productions and then he's constantly
writing pilots and movies I mean he's
he's constantly on just the edge of I
feel blowing up he just needs that one
that one exact to read one a script and
he'll have a TV show or a movie or
whatever he's probably got stacks upon
stacks upon stacks he's a writing Sivan
he stays busy he does he keeps the bit
the pin down again if he's not writing
for somebody else he's writing for
himself and again he's just getting
better and better and better so do you
do you see yourself ironically as
somewhat of a news guy now I mean not
certainly not completely I mean I hear
kind of the heart behind what you want
to where you want to be in terms of
creating things but none of us your your
public profile is kind of a news guy now
none of us consistent I don't think I'm
stepping out of bounds by saying in to
everybody on SourceFed I don't think I
am I can't think of somebody that would
disagree with this thinks that they're a
journalist or thinks that they're a news
guy we all consider ourselves
entertainers that are creating on a news
aggregate we research and read other
people's actual journalism that go out
in the actual field and interview actual
human beings and we take that
information and we turn it into
something that is informational and
hopefully entertaining and we are we are
a connector to I journal ISM I feel like
we open up the doors to events in the
world to people that don't want to watch
see at CNN and CNN and then CNN or MSNBC
is the problem why did they name it that
No so I think we're more of we open
doors to that world but I don't I don't
consider myself a news person and
anybody that says to me you're the only
person I get my news from I go that's a
horrible decision and you should
probably get some other sources and
because you should do that anyways you
shouldn't just be going to CNN and and
then or MSN and NBC you know you got to
bounce around and formulate your own
opinion I don't know Joe I I feel like
that kind of sounds like a like a
cop-out sure because you think that's
like Jon Stewart saying he's not a real
journalist yeah I think to me I think
like I certainly don't look down my nose
if when asking the question do you
consider yourself a news guy a newsman
or whatever I mean there's certainly
it's an interesting opportunity a
position that you're in if people are
getting their news from you it there's a
there's a there's an implied level of
responsibility that if I were you I
guess I wouldn't be that comfortable
with I agree with what you're saying
because wow they're only gonna listen to
me and which is why I tell them to not
yeah but I do I do look at Jon Stewart
look at the look at that dude he'd give
you the same answer that I just gave you
an interesting dynamic though is it weed
and even though GMM is not a news show
there's we don't have someone here on
staff who is going out and getting to
the bottom of something we're reading
blogs we're reading news sites right
where we're finding articles that have
been posted yeah you and you and so in
that sense your death you don't have
that at source feather you're you're
taking it you're presenting the news in
an entertaining way it is I do at times
feel not like we're being irresponsible
but more like yeah there's somebody out
there actually got this story I don't
know how that person I don't know how
it's perfect I don't know how that
person got the story but we're taking
that I don't think it's unfair to actual
journalists to consider ourselves to
journalists I would say we're oh okay
one if you want to attach the word News
let's say we're news personalities and
if that's the case they debt they they
need to know what their
singing - which is why I say you need to
listen to other people because I'm just
giving you well you guys want an
unbiased take on the news well I didn't
create I'm not researching this I'm
reading somebody else's take which is
probably self of somebody else's take
which is off of another actual
journalists work but I do agree that
there is a responsibility with us to
present it not just in an entertaining
way which is how I feel
SourceFed is the number one thing is
entertainment than informational but a
lot of people do see it the other way
informational and then entertainment
wise and just this week I redid a story
it was one of the first times that I
ever did it because I was about this
this lady that yeah and I sued the
family of the boy that she actually
killed so she hit a kid with her car
late night kid died and then turns out
all the the news reports were saying she
was suing the family and the dead kid
for for money and I was like that's
[ __ ] and then I made a video where I
was just it was just it was just rage I
just didn't it was incredible they used
the word bias but it was just a reaction
is what it was and I was like this is
how this made me feel and then got a lot
of blowback for it in the sense of oh
this is incredibly biased you didn't
read this and this and this and you
didn't take this lady's side into
consideration that's like well we're not
journalists where we need to be a
hundred percent unbiased all the time
again we are reacting to other people's
hard work so anyways I went back and I
watched the video and I didn't like how
I did it it was a reactionary it was it
was again it was almost like blind rage
I used I just described the woman in
very very vivid terms in a very negative
light I was like well okay well I think
this story probably deserves a little
bit more of both sides so I went back
and I I made a second video where I
discussed both sides a little bit more
gave the the devil's advocate of both
situations and then I was like here's my
opinion and that's really probably how a
lot of things should be done in that
realm but in the
of making five videos a day with a lot
of turnaround week we can't put that
much time in research and energy into
every single video like a real
journalist I get it and the interesting
thing is you're also you're not just a
news personality you're an Internet
personality which carries with it people
want to know you they want to know your
opinion they want to know you as a
person I've you know the success of
SourceFed that's yeah that's why
SourceFed works in other ways that these
other news personalities don't because
Phil knew you know oh people like
personalities so he was like I'm gonna
get people that people will like you
know to do this and so you know that's
why that's why ultimately a guy like
Elliot can go and try to do something on
his own because everybody knows him and
likes him now you know but again
personalities and entertainers first
that happened to be doing a new show and
I'm interested you know when you look at
something like Table Talk as a series I
was curious if you found yourself
sharing more of the real Joe because of
the off-the-cuff nature of Table Talk I
mean you you're a sketch comedy guy
who's found himself in a news
environment news entertainer will say we
use apply that only but then a step
further as as close as maybe you you
never thought you'd get so close to
being a vlogger that you're sharing
personal experiences like just oh your
mom's yeah yeah so I was curious if you
found yourself sharing more of yourself
with the audience because you I've
always had the impression that you're
kind of a guarded guy but my theory is
that with Table Talk you find yourself
talking and sharing more of yourself
than you instinctively would share as
Joe I think I'll always be a storyteller
in the sense when we're sitting here
together shooting the crap that I've
never I've never had a filter in that
sense but I do have a filter in there
are a bunch of things in my life that
nobody needs to know
I don't like I know when to talk about
things and what not to talk about things
so if I have a funny story or something
that I feel like will educate somebody
or give some perspective I'll tell that
but I've never vlog because I don't feel
like everything about my family is
anybody's business but my own
and that's why I've never been much
about you know picking up the camera and
putting every bit of my life online for
everybody to see because I don't want my
life to become a reality show and I kind
of want some of that just for me you
know yeah yeah I don't know I there's I
will tell almost anything and everything
but there's always gonna be a line for
me we started as sketch comedians and
entertainers online and I feel like
we've always enjoyed the fourth wall the
fourth walls always been an important
thing to us but at over time SourceFed
and me just realizing the nature of
YouTube and the audience on YouTube you
have to break down that fourth wall a
little bit because it isn't television
YouTube is creating that community and
building that community and I'm Way more
okay with that now than I was 10 years
ago and it all started but I'll never I
don't think I'll ever be that vlogger
guy I think for me and I could be wrong
because I'm not the audience I
entertainer comedian fourth-wall Joe
will always for me be more entertaining
than just what I do during my everyday
life but maybe I'm wrong maybe I should
have been I've been wrong about YouTube
all the time program that's Stu but
nobody's gonna do that the audience will
just recoil and stop watching well I've
certainly enjoyed the candid side of Joe
here and taking a trip down memory lane
appreciate that yeah well you know you
see what a rambling you haven't figured
out YouTube but you're doing something
right it's been YouTube's been good to
me very video you're doing something
right or else you know we wouldn't have
you at the roundtable of dim lighting
signature I mean we're friends I'm gonna
we'd have him just because we're friends
but that's not why we the first time we
ever hung out was that a bar just down
the road from here it was a British
positive British column old British pub
all right man sign
I will alright Phil say goodbye to your
signature buddy huh yeah oh he's working
right through right and there it was
our Joe Bereta ear biscuit you know he's
one of the only examples I could think
of of someone who has essentially
reinvented himself on YouTube I mean
yeah they're from the very beginning top
three most subscribed channel with
barats and bereta but then yeah you know
it's fascinating to hear the story that
kind of led to being a shaping force in
the whole format of SourceFed I mean
getting in on the ground loved ones and
inventing how that SourceFed was gonna
work and continues to work to this day
even with a lot of new hosts a lot of
credit goes to Joe and it reinvent
reinvented himself as a part of that you
know yeah I can't think of another
example there may be on YouTube but
YouTube hasn't been around that long for
and for people to for enough people to
reinvent themselves yeah well it's you
know it's a pioneer in that way right
it's tough enough to just do one thing
to figure out what you're doing the one
thing that you're doing right and it and
I think it's cool that there's people
who would just know Oh Joe yeah from
SourceFed oh you mean he's also part of
a comedy duo that has this this history
and had this huge success and had these
opportunities
yeah be something that thing you know
but I just think it just goes to show
you that he's got that he's got that
skill set and I and I do think I will
not be surprised at all when I hear that
Joe has got something else cooking is I
mean maybe that's a breath and bread a
thing maybe that's just a Joe Bereta
thing but he's a smart guy he's a
talented guy
and he's a great family man he's always
got that motivation you got a lot
a lot of respect for Joe and you know
high hopes for everything that he's
going to do and yeah I mean I'm excited
to hear about you and Luke continuing to
work together you know I was kind of
afraid to hear that he might tell us all
Buress and bereta it's basically over
guys you know but I was encouraged to
hear that that's not the case that you
know there could be some there could be
some more and I hope there will be and
what's too good of a name I mean you
know barats and bereta even even rai
asking to be comedic ly do lo realize
forever you got a pair those names up I
mean one is a name of a gun you know I
don't know what Borat the other one is
verrat yeah they sound good together
both got a story well when you when you
abbreviate them b and b it's like
bed-and-breakfast they could you know
what they could just have a
bed-and-breakfast brass and bread a
bed-and-breakfast hmm I'd be into that I
like a better breakfast do you like a
bed and breakfast I love it I think you
might even like a better breakfast more
than I do I don't particularly like
eating breakfast with strangers is there
one reason is the main downfall of the
bed-and-breakfast but if Jo and Luke are
there I'm not strangers right it's just
like yeah you guys you guys are here
every day you didn't have to make this
for me gosh can I not tomorrow I'll make
something for you we should have told
him about that well he liked your
sausage mixed in with your scrambled
eggs cuz that's one of my favorite
things to eat I could learn how to make
it I like a no-life me I like an omelet
I like an omelet station in a better
better breakfast surely they can figure
that out one of them can like a pancake
with a with an apple slice in it
what happens added at a
bed-and-breakfast I got one of those one
time
it's a zenus is it a circular apple
slice like it's been circus a circle cut
no just like some cross-sections of
apple and a pancake I love what you know
let's take care of that on our own time
let's wrap up this here biscuit I'm
interested good I want you to call this
thing hope we could have called this
podcast Apple and Castle up with apple
and a pancake apple pancakes but it's
here biscuits and we can't change it now
dangling you gotta cuz some good ideas
you just came up with this on yourself
your own
no I I ate at a bed-and-breakfast many
years ago and they offered it to you
that I the Outer Banks they said you
want an apple in your belly they didn't
even ask they just gave it to me Wow
okay well that's rock my world
well again guys thank you for being with
us for this episode of Apple and a
pancake I think your special apple
pancakes
it's got Laurel be sure to let Joe
Bereta know on Twitter what you think of
his ear biscuit also hashtag ear
biscuits it up to share the love and let
us know on iTunes what you think about
the podcast remember leaving a review
hitting that little star button the more
stars the better that helps up a lot and
you can leave a comment on Soundcloud
and we will do this again next week
because you can count on us and I know
we can count on you because I know you
you think we can get one of those Apple
pancakes right now I'm not gonna make it
if that's what you're asking
well maybe next week
[Music]
[Music]